So we're,
we're going to continue that discussion of cardiovascular physiology today in
particular,
pay attention to the heart and its role in creating the pressure that moves
blood throughout the circulatory system.
So I'm going to take a step back and let's review what we talked about at the
end and then we'll,
we'll get into the,
into the new material for today.
Yeah.
Um,
so the heart is an element of the circulatory system.
It's a critical element obviously.
Um,
and it,
it,
you can show it as in this picture in the center of the circulatory system where
its role is to supply the pressure drop that moves blood through what's called
the systemic circulation or the circulation to all of the tissues in the body.
The circulation of oxygen,
rich blood to all the tissues in the body,
flowing from the aorta through arteries,
through arterials,
capillaries,
collecting vein,
Ya'lls back to veins,
back to the heart.
And the second circulatory system,
the pulmonary circulatory system,
which sends deoxygenated or oxygen poor blood through the lungs,
through the pulmonary artery,
arterials,
capillaries,
veins back through the back,
through the pulmonary vein,
uh,
to the left side of the heart.
And so one can think about the heart as to functioning units that are coupled in
some way.
And we're going to see that there coupled in almost every way that they're
coupled because the output from one side of the heart is the input to the other
side,
right?
The output from the left side of the heart goes through this circuit and then
back to the right side,
the output from the right side goes through this circuit and then back to the
left side.
So they're coupled and there are also coupled because it's one organ.
And so when this Oregon,
uh,
performs its function,
which is contraction,
uh,
these things are happening simultaneously,
right?
Because it's one individual Oregon that's accomplishing it.
Yeah.
We talked briefly about the anatomy of the heart and I brought a model of the
heart here,
larger than actual size,
uh,
but with,
and so it's not like a real heart in that way.
It's also not like a real heart because you can open it up and take a look
inside.
And uh,
so I'm going to bring this to section if you want to look at it or you can come
up and look at it after class.
But to illustrate some of the features that are shown in this cartoon that,
um,
there's a difference in the muscular,
uh,
walls that the left side of the heart has a thicker muscle than the right side
of the heart and that,
um,
there are vessels on the surface of the heart.
So vessels that come off of the aorta,
for example,
the red here that served the myocardium or the surface of the heart and supply
it with oxygen,
that the right and left side of the heart is divided into two chambers.
On the left side there's the left ventricle and the left atrium above it,
right ventricle,
right atrium above it.
Yeah.
And if you look inside,
there are valves that guard the entrance is between these compartments.
So there's a valve and going from the right atrium to the right ventricle.
Okay,
I'm just going to put all the names up on the,
um,
there's a valve than going from the right atrium,
right atrium to the right ventral,
and that's called the tricuspid valve.
There's a valve in going from the right ventricle into the pulmonary artery,
and that's called the pulmonary valve.
Um,
you can't see it very well here,
but it's up here.
There's a valve and going from the left atrium into the left ventricle,
and that's called the mitral valve.
And a valve in going from the left atrium into the aorta.
And that's called the aortic valve.
Okay.
So there's four valves,
uh,
that are important and they guard the entrances.
And one of the key things we're going to talk about today is the function of
these valves in producing a flow.
So you know that the heart functions,
it creates pressure by,
uh,
by,
by beating,
by contracting,
right?
It beats and how his pressure generated,
uh,
when that happens,
you know that blood moves,
blood flows because of a pressure drop.
And we talked last time about the regulation ship between a pressure drop and a
flow.
So wherever there's a pressure drop,
if there's the possibility of flow,
there's some resistance to that flow and a certain amount of flow is created,
which depends on the resistance.
Resistance goes up,
flow goes down for fixed pressure drop resistance goes down,
flow goes up for a fixed pressure drops.
So the pressure drop is what creates the flow.
You also know that pressure varies with volume.
If I have a container that contains a liquid or a gas and I compressed the
container,
the pressure goes up inside.
Why is that?
Why does pressure go up?
As volume goes down,
the most simple system to think about is,
is an ideal gas,
right?
In an ideal gas law,
PV equals NRT,
right?
In an ideal gas pressure times the volume
equals n.
R.
T.
If,
if temperature,
the gas constant and the number of molecules are constant,
then when pressure goes up,
volume has to go down,
right?
Volume goes down,
pressure goes up.
Why is that?
What's happening inside
Brian?
Right,
exactly.
So,
so the molecules are closer together,
closer to the walls.
The for force of pressure is created by collisions and the molecules with the
walls.
This is a very simple description obviously,
but you can imagine as the volume goes down,
then the pressure goes up.
More molecules bouncing against the walls and creating pressure.
Same thing happens in a liquid only in a liquid.
That change is not so dramatic,
right?
As in,
as in an ideal gas in general,
liquids are considered to be incompressible or you're not pushing their
molecules closer together.
Uh,
so much because they're,
it's a condensed fluid,
but pressure still varies with volume.
And the same way you can't describe it,
but by this equation anymore because this only applies for ideal gases.
But the same thing is true that when volume goes down,
the volume and the number of molecules is fixed,
then the pressure goes up,
right?
And so,
uh,
another way of thinking about it that is far less scientific is because
everybody's seen star wars,
right?
Not the,
not the later imitation star wars,
but the first one,
right?
Where Luke Skywalker gets trapped with,
uh,
somebody,
I forget even who get trapped in,
in this,
in this room,
in this garbage dump,
and the walls start coming in and as the walls start coming in,
uh,
he gets more and more urgent about getting out right?
As pressure is going up,
as the volume is going down and the pressure to get out,
it gets higher and higher.
It's the same kind of thing here,
right?
Volume is decreasing.
Pressure goes up
when the heart beats or contracts,
it decreases the volume of these chambers.
When the muscle contracts,
it decreases the volume of the chambers inside.
The volume of the chambers goes down and there's blood inside and that blood
gets squeezed as the pressure.
As the volume goes down,
the pressure goes up.
Okay?
So that's how pressure is generated.
Why do you need valves?
Why?
Why are valid is important and the function of the heart,
and I already alluded to the fact that that your heart cannot function properly
without valves that are acting correctly.
So why do you need a valve?
We'll imagine that you had a simpler system than your heart.
You had a balloon that was attached to a garden hose and,
and the whole thing was filled with water.
And so if I,
if I decrease the volume of the balloon,
the pressure and the balloon goes up and water goes out the garden hose,
right?
If I decreased the volume,
What if I expand it again?
Well then the,
then the pressure goes down inside the garden hose and all the water gets sucked
back in.
So you can imagine if you had a water hose that a garden hose that was hooked up
to a reservoir and a balloon on one end and you inflated it and deflated it
inflated and deflated it,
you'd be pushing water out and pulling it in and it would go back and forth in
this way.
And if you're increasing and decreasing the volume by the same amount,
she'd be pushing out a volume of water and pulling it back in.
Right now that's a kind of a flow,
but it's not the continuous one directional kind of flow that we have in our
circulatory systems.
Right?
That would be,
you could imagine a circulatory system that's based on that where you have a
heart that pushes blood out and then sucks it back in and pushes it out and
sucks it back in.
But that's not the way that that the human heart functions.
In order to get blood flowing in one direction,
you push the blood out,
you close a gate and then when you're reinflating the heart,
the blood can't come back.
Okay.
So the function of these valves is to,
to prevent that reverse flow of blood back into the heart when it's relaxing or
increasing its volume.
Okay.
So the basic function of the heart is to contract,
decrease its volume,
increase the pressure blood goes out,
valve closes,
preventing blood from coming back into the chamber that just ejected the blood
and then that chamber relaxes and goes back to its original volume.
Okay?
That's the basic function of the heart and we're going to spend the rest of the
time talking about the details of how that happens,
but she's clear why valves are necessary part of that cycle.
Okay?
Pressure varies throughout the circulatory system.
If pressure's indeed generated in the heart,
as I said,
then you would expect the highest pressures to be in the regions that are
closest to the heart.
So if I measured pressure in the aorta,
and we talked about this last time,
you would find that pressure varies with time,
right?
Because pressure's going up and down in the heart that that oscillation in
pressure with heartbeat gets transmitted into the aorta as well.
And we'll talk in a minute about why that happens.
But if you looked over time,
an average pressure in the aorta would be somewhere between 120 and 80
millimeters of mercury.
So let's just call it 90 here.
So the pressure in the aorta is 90 now if you think about the whole circuit,
right?
This blood has to flow from the aorta through the systemic circulation and back
into the right atrium and the right atrium.
It's at the end of its journey and that pressure there is approximately zero.
Bless you.
So the pressure drop that's driving blood through the systemic circulatory
system is Delta p of 90 minus zero.
All right.
The pressure that's generated here gets used completely in driving the flow
around.
And if I looked at intermediate positions,
I'd find that if I looked in the arterials,
the pressures about 35 millimeters of mercury.
So the pressure drop from here to here is a 55 millimeters of mercury.
The pressure drop from the arterioles to the vein Ewells is about 20 millimeters
of mercury.
And from the venules back to the right atrium is 15 minus zero or a 15
millimeters of mercury,
right?
So pressure drops throughout the circulatory system.
If you look on the pulmonary side,
you'll find the same phenomenon,
but in general,
the pressures are lower.
Okay.
The pressure in the pulmonary artery is only about 15 millimeters of mercury
dropping to about six millimeters of mercury in the capillaries where oxygen
exchange occurs,
dropping back to zero.
When you get to the,
uh,
to the left atrium.
So what does that tell you about the pulmonary circulation compared to the
systemic circulation?
The pressure drop across the systemic circulation is 90 millimeters of mercury
across the pulmonary circulation is 15 millimeters of mercury.
What does that tell you about the pulmonary circulation in comparison to the
systemic circulation?
Justin
flows not as fast.
Is that true?
Okay.
What do you think?
Okay,
so what's the,
what's the flow through the aorta?
Yeah,
it's,
it's five liters per minute.
And I think that was a good answer.
The flow might be not as fast because there's not as much of a pressure drop.
But we know because this is an interconnected system,
that the flow is actually five liters per minute at every cross,
every location in the circulatory system.
Right.
It's a continuous circuit.
So the flow has to be the same everywhere.
Okay.
So Justin's answer was one possibility and it's a good one,
but that doesn't work in this connected kind of a system.
So then if the flow is the same,
what has to be different?
Yeah,
I'm sorry Naomi.
Okay.
It doesn't have to go to the rest of the body,
so it doesn't have to generate as much pressure.
So yeah.
So you're on the right track.
So what does that tell you in terms of the numbers you were dealing with on your
homework?
Which system has a higher resistance?
The systemic system has a higher resistance because it takes a higher pressure
drop in order to create the same flow.
So the systemic sit,
sit circulation has a higher resistance in the pulmonary circulation,
high resistance,
high pressure circuit,
low resistance,
low pressure circuit.
And there's consequences of that.
Right.
And it sort of makes sense now that you've done your homework problem for this
week,
that the resistance to the pulmonary system would be less because you don't have
so far to travel,
right.
The,
the blood have so far to travel,
so the length is much less.
You don't have to push the blood is far.
It doesn't have to go up to your head and down to your toes.
And so less overall resistance and because it has less resistance,
you don't need as much pressure drop because you don't need as much pressure
drop.
You don't need it as much muscle.
I don't need to generate as high a pressure.
So the right side has less muscle mass than the left side.
And the reason for more muscle mass on the lesson is to create the higher
pressure that's needed to drive this high resistance circuit.
Right.
This diagram shows you the events in what's called the cardiac cycle.
The cardiac cycle is this rhythmic movement that we call a heartbeat and it goes
through a very systematic,
uh,
cycle.
It's a cycle.
So you could start and end ended anywhere.
We're going to start in this region of the cycle that's called late diastole and
diastole is the relaxation phase.
Diastole is the relaxation phase.
Systally is the contraction phase.
So in late diastole,
that's the moment right before the beat starts or the contraction starts,
and in late diastole,
look at the situation here.
There's blood flowing back into the atria coming from the circulation that's
driven by the pressure created by the last heartbeat.
And there's some,
there's some,
uh,
blood moving from the atrium into the ventricle.
And that's true because this valve,
the mitral valve is open.
Okay?
The mitral valve is open,
so blood is flowing back to the left atrium and back into the left ventricle.
The heart is relaxed.
It's passively flowing into the heart.
Okay?
Right at the beginning of contraction.
Another word for contraction is systally diastole.
Systally.
Now the heart starts to contract,
but one region of the heart starts to contract first.
The contraction occurs in an orderly fashion.
It starts in the atria and it moves to the ventricles.
So first,
the Atrium contract there.
If you look at this,
they are not very muscular.
They have muscles,
but they're not anything like the ventricle.
So you can think of it as a weaker muscle than the ventricle is,
but it contracts first and when it can tracks,
the volume decreases,
it increases the pressure inside the atrium and more blood starts flowing from
the atrium into the ventricle,
right?
More blood starts flowing from the atrium into the ventricle.
So what happens,
this contraction decreases.
The volume,
increases the pressure,
increases the pressure drop between the Atrium and the ventricle and more blood
gets,
uh,
gets flows into the ventricle.
Now the contraction moves to the ventricle,
the ventricle starts to contract.
And when it contracts,
the pressure starts going up inside.
When the pressure goes up inside the mitral closes,
that's important cause you don't want blood to flow back into the Atrium and
back into the,
uh,
into the pulmonary vein.
So the mitral valve closes and this contraction starts in during,
in a period called ISO volume metric contraction.
And this ISO volume metric contraction means that both of the entrances,
both the entrance and the exit into the ventricle or closed the mitral valve is
closed.
The aortic valve is closed,
contraction is proceeding.
So the volume is decreased as trying to decrease,
but it can't.
So the pressure goes up
right during contraction to the point where the aortic valve opens.
Now this is pressurized blood,
which is ejected
pressurized blood,
which is ejected through the aorta,
flow through the aorta,
and then,
uh,
and then the aortic valve closes again when diastole is complete.
So just focus on what's happening on the left side.
The right side is doing the same thing,
but just at lower pressures,
right?
Sisterly Begins Atria contracts,
blood flows into the ventricle,
ventricle contracts,
both the doors are closed,
the valves are closed,
pressure gets higher pressures,
and then eventually the aortic valve opens.
And you get this,
this event called ventricular ejection where a volume of blood bursts out of the
ventricle into the aorta.
The aortic valve closes again and the cycle repeats itself,
right?
So this is a schematic diagram to show you sort of the sequence of events,
contraction and valve activity that lead to the forward surge of blood.
The amount of blood that is ejected from the left ventricle on each cycle is
called the ejection volume.
If you took the ejection volume and multiplied it by the heart rate,
you get the cardiac output,
right?
So the ejection volume or the volume of blood
that's,
that's um,
that's ejected from the ventricle on each beat times the heart rate is equal to
that cardiac output,
right?
You know,
this is five,
um,
five approximately at rest,
five liters per minute.
If you assume that your cardiac output while you're sitting there is five liters
permitted and you put your finger on your pulse and measure your heart rate,
then you could calculate approximately how much blood is being ejected from the
ventricle with each beat.
All right.
So let's think about that same kind thing and more detailed what we really track
the pressures because it turns out that following the pressures and thinking
about what's happening in the chambers and the valves,
you can get fairly complete picture of the physics of how cardiac ejection
occurs.
And so this diagram is,
it's,
it's in the powerpoints and uh,
but it's a little hard to see,
I think on the,
on the projection.
So I redrew it down here in color.
Uh,
but what it shows is pressure from zero to one 20.
Okay.
Right.
As a function of time during the cardiac cycle.
So I didn't,
I didn't write any time units on here,
but this is time progressing and this shows you two beats of the heart.
And the most prominent thing that you notice is the Green Line here,
which shows pressure in the,
did I erase it and the ventricle,
which ventricle am I showing?
Okay.
How would you tell,
I said they're both,
both roughly the same,
but how would you tell if this was the left or the right ventricle?
The total pressure and the pressure's high,
right?
It's so this must be the left ventricle because it's,
it's,
it's reaching about 90 millimeters of mercury.
The pressure you need to drive the systemic circulation.
This isn't,
this is emptied,
the left,
the left ventricle,
and it's the left atrium.
You could have also noticed,
this is the aorta I'm going to show you here.
So,
um,
if I'm showing the unit,
it must be the left side of the,
of the heart.
But the first thing you notice is this big bump in pressure.
This is the trace for the ventricle.
If I had a pressure sensor in the ventricle and I was measuring how pressure
changed as a function of,
of a time,
I would measure what you see on this Green Line here.
And pressure starts off fairly low and then goes up to 120 millimeters of
mercury and goes back down again up to 120 millimeters mercury down.
Again,
this is the trace for the atrium on the bottom here,
you'll notice that the pressure in the atrium doesn't go through these big
excursions that the ventricle does.
And that's because the atrium is not a powerful pump,
right?
It's not a powerful,
uh,
muscle.
And so it only generates a little bit of pressure when it contracts and the role
of the Atrium is to contract to basically fill up the ventricle so that when the
ventricle goes through its massive contraction,
it's as full of blood as it can be.
So the Atrium gives a little beat in order to push whatever blood is in it into
the ventricle,
doesn't have to go very far,
so you don't need so much pressure and fill up the ventricles so that when the
ventricle contracts,
you get as much ejection of blood as possible.
The biggest volume injected possible.
If I looked at the difference in pressures between the Atrium and the ventricle
at this point here and this point here where I'm starting is late in diastole,
remember what was happening late in diastole was that blood is flowing from the
left atrium into the left ventricle and the mitral valve is open.
And that's what you see here.
The pressure is slightly higher in the atrium than it is in the ventricle.
So if I looked at the pressure drop at this point,
Delta p is moot.
It's Po,
it's,
it's higher in the atrium that it is in the ventricle and so blood is naturally
flowing that way,
but that only happens if the mitral valve is open
and it is at this point the mitral valve is open during diastole.
Okay.
The atrium contracts,
you see the little bump of pressure created by the Atrium contraction and then
the ventricle contracts,
so this is the start of systally
right here where the contraction of the Atrium starts is the beginning of the
heartbeat.
What happens,
the atrium contracts pressure stays higher in the atrium that it is in the
ventricle and so blood is flowing from the atrium into the ventricle and then
all of a sudden the ventricle starts contracting.
Okay.
The ventricle has a bigger contraction,
right.
More muscle.
So it's going to generate more pressure at some point,
very shortly after it starts to contract,
the pressure in the ventricle becomes higher than the pressure in the atrium.
Yeah.
When the pressure in the ventricle becomes higher than the pressure in the
atrium,
the valve between them,
the mitral valve closes.
Okay.
And it closes strictly due to the fact,
well there it closes for a number of reasons,
but one of the reasons that closes because there's more pressure here now than
there is here and it slams the door shut.
Okay.
It's a one way valve.
When pressure becomes higher in the ventricle,
in the atrium,
the valve closes.
Okay,
so at this point here where the lines cross,
this is the mitral valve closing.
Okay.
What's happening at the other,
at,
at the exit?
Well,
the aorta is this,
the pressure in the aorta is this orange line here.
The pressure in the aorta is high.
Why is the pressure in the aorta high?
Because it was filled up with blood from the last heartbeat.
It was,
it,
it was,
this blood was ejected into the aorta at high pressure.
That pressure stays there from the last heartbeat.
Okay.
Now why does it do that?
Because the aortic valve is closed
during,
um,
during diastole.
Okay.
The aortic valve is closed and that means that the pressure that was generated
stays high in the aorta,
even as the ventricle is relaxing.
Okay.
The blood can't get sucked back from the aorta into the ventricle because at
this point the aortic valve is closed.
Okay.
When the mitral valve closes,
okay.
the aortic valve is already closed.
That means the ventricle is sealed off,
right?
That's what I showed you in the diagram here.
Uh,
right after atrial systally.
Okay.
Both valves are closed and the ventricle is contracting because both valves are
closed and the ventricle is contracting.
We have,
uh,
we have the Luke Skywalker situation where pressure starts to rise dramatically
inside the closed chamber.
Eventually that pressure is gonna rise high enough that the pressure in the
ventricle crosses over the pressure in the aorta
and at this point,
what happens?
Yeah.
The aortic valve opens.
Okay.
At this point,
the aortic valve opens.
Yeah.
And blood can be ejected from the ventricle into the aorta.
Now that's the only path for the blood to go because the mitral valve is still
closed and the mitral valve is still closed because the pressure in the
ventricle is still much higher than it is in the atrium.
Okay.
So what this diagram shows you is a couple of different things.
It shows you pressure in each of the chambers thinking about the chamber,
the atrium,
the ventricle,
the aorta,
and depending on where one pressure sits with respect to the other,
if the pressure in the ventricle is higher than the pressure in the aorta than
the aortic valve is open.
Okay?
If it's the other way,
the aortic valve is closed and the same thing with the ventricle and the uh,
and the atrium.
The ethnic valve opens here,
contraction continues and this is the active phase of ejection,
which is shown in the diagram here.
Mitral valve closed,
aortic valve open pressure high here,
pressure lower here.
So blood is ejected from the heart.
The muscle eventually starts to relax.
Contraction is complete.
The ventricle starts relaxing when the ventricular pressure passes.
Okay.
Through this point and drops below the aortic pressure than the aortic valve
closes.
Yeah.
When the ventricular pressure at the ventricle continues relax,
eventually it falls even below the pressure in the atrium and the um,
and the mitral valve opens.
Okay.
And the ventricle begins refilling for the next,
for the next contraction.
All right,
this makes sense.
So it's this,
this diagram,
if you understand this diagram,
then you understand the biophysics of of pressure generation and flow generation
by the heart.
It's a little bit hard to grasp all at once,
but if you walk through it in the way that I showed you a,
then I think you'll begin to understand it.
And another way to understand it is to look at this diagram.
I've shown it a little bit more clearly here.
The mitral valve closing aortic valve opening I Arctic valve closing,
mitral valve reopening.
And if you can follow the pressures and keep this diagram in mind,
why those valves open at the times they do make sense.
All right.
And the fact that they opened in the sequence,
they do allow the heart to undergo a cyclic contraction and relaxation,
which results in a net forward flow of blood.
Right?
This shows just where,
uh,
the,
active contraction of systally and diastally fall on this curve.
Sisterly begins when the Atrium begins to contract atrium contracts,
ventricle contracts,
systally ends here and the ventricle starts to relax at that point.
And that's diastole.
Early Diastole,
the ventricle is still relaxing late diastole.
Everything is fully relaxed and prepared for the next heartbeat.
Okay.
What's the time of this whole sequence?
Well,
how fast,
what's a heart rate?
You know,
60 to 70 beats per minute.
So this whole sequence here takes about a second.
All right.
Athletes,
it's well known training,
uh,
can decrease your heart rate.
What does that tell you?
Uh,
do athletes need less blood flow?
Okay.
No,
they need about the same blood flow,
but they have a higher ejection volume,
so their,
their heart is operating very efficiently,
ejecting more volume per beat,
and so they need less beats to supply that cardiac output.
There are other changes that occur during training as well.
It's not,
that's not the only thing,
but that's one thing that certainly occurs.
And as you become more cardiovascular,
as your cardiovascular fitness increases,
you can,
what happens when you start to exercise,
two things happen when you start to exercise.
One is your heart rate goes,
the second is your heart starts beating with more force.
So both the heart rate and the ejection volume go up in order to create more
cardiac output.
A conditioned athlete,
uh,
we'll be able to do both of those very efficiently.
And so they can create a higher cardiac output with less work from the heart.
Right?
And that's why with conditioning and training,
you can start to be,
uh,
you know more,
your performance will be enhanced even though your heart rate might not go up as
someone who,
who is out of a condition.
Right?
This is just another picture of the cardiac cycle where now I've,
I've sort of combined everything together so that you can see this pressure
curve here,
the pressure curve for the aorta,
for the ventricle,
for the atrium.
And you can,
uh,
you can visually correlate that with what's happening in each event.
Late diastole,
all the muscles are relaxed and blood is passively flowing back into the left
atrium and the,
and through the mitral valve,
which is open to the left ventricle.
When contraction begins first in the atrium,
blood is pumped into the ventricle.
The role of atrial contraction is roughly to fill up the ventricle as much as
possible.
When the ventricle starts to contract,
pressure in the ventricle rises above pressure in the atrium causing the mitral
valve to close.
The aortic valve was already closed.
So now you have a closed chamber here and this contraction is an ISO volume
metric contraction,
fixed volume of blood trying to increase top,
trying to working the hardest working to try to decrease the volume it can't.
So the pressure goes up when the pressure goes up above what it is in the aorta,
the aortic valve opens,
blood is ejected,
that muscle starts to relax and the aortic valve closes.
And this is key,
right?
If your aortic valve didn't close,
what would happen here?
Okay.
You'd pull in that blood that you just ejected into the order,
you'd pull it back into the ventricle.
A little bit does come back because the valve doesn't close immediately.
Right?
A little bit does come back.
Uh,
but,
but not very much
when,
um,
when positions are listening to your heart,
one of the things they're listening for is sounds that aren't normally present
in a functioning heart.
And those sounds often have to do with valves that are not functioning properly.
So if during a late a systally,
if right after systally is over,
if they hear a wash of blood when they shouldn't,
that might be because your aortic valve isn't functioning properly and blood is
wishing back into the ventricle when it shouldn't be.
Same thing with the mitral valve.
If they hear a noise at this point in the cardiac cycle,
if they hear a noise at this point in the cardiac cycle,
that might be a flow of blood back from the ventricle into the atrium when it
shouldn't be happening.
That might be because your mitral valve is not functioning properly.
And so that's,
that's what,
that's what physicians are listening for when they listen to your chest during a
physical exam.
Wilma
here.
Yeah.
So what causes this little blip of pressure here after the mitral valve closes
do you think?
Okay,
well it,
it's,
it's probably happens just because you're getting this massive contraction in
the ventricle that's right underneath it.
And so there's some change in volume here as well.
Even though the atrial contraction is almost complete,
you're also getting sort of a bystander effect from this very large contraction
down here.
And so that is follows very closely the pressure rise in the ventricle and is
just a byproduct of that.
Other questions,
what I want to talk about.
So that's the end of the material that's covered on your midterm exam,
which is next Thursday.
Uh,
what I want to talk about next week is on Tuesday is the cardiac conduction
system.
And I think you can see now that for this,
uh,
for this orderly sequence of events to occur,
it has to be regulated in some way.
It has to be regulated in some way.
And that the proper function of your heart requires all these things to occur in
a very specific sequence,
right?
The atrium has to contract before the ventricle,
And um,
in order for this,
this,
this logical progression of pressures,
proper functioning of the valves,
et Cetera,
well,
it's the cardiac conduction system or this specialized system that moves
electrical impulses through the heart that is responsible for coordinating the
function of the heart on a heartbeat.
And the cardiac conduction system is an electrical system where impulses are
carried,
uh,
through the,
through the substance of the heart.
Now,
heart tissue is muscular tissue.
It's also electrically active tissue and each of the cells are capable of
undergoing an action potential,
just like action potentials in nerves.
But the action potential in a muscle cell is not strictly informational like it
is in the nervous system,
right?
Action potential was the way that an electrical signal got propagated from one
end of the nerve to the other.
Well,
in muscle cells,
electrical signals get propagated from one muscle cell to another,
but another thing happens and that this electrical signal also activates the
contraction mechanism inside cells.
So as they're passing the electrical signal,
they're also getting the message to contract.
Okay.
Electrical activity and muscle cells is linked to contraction.
And so as this electrical activity passes over the heart in an orderly fashion
because of the cardiac conduction system,
as it passes in an orderly fashion over the surface of the heart,
as we'll see next time I'm showing it this way,
this is the way the electrical signal passes from right atrium down through left
ventricle as it passes in that orderly way than muscles are activated to
contract in orderly way as well.
So I'd like you to review for next time what we talked about in terms of action
potentials that are in chapter six because we're going to go to talk about those
in the context of a heart,
uh,
for next time.
Okay.
Questions?
So I'll see you this afternoon.